This is 99% invisible. I'm Roman Mars. Barbara Visser was 9 years old the first time she saw it. She was on a school field trip to the Stadelic Art Museum in the center of Amsterdam. I guess it's about 1975. One could say it's the heyday of that museum. They were really at the forefront of modern and contemporary art. The Stadelic was built to impress. There was a huge stairway leading up to the light in a way, a bit biblical, a stairway,
这里是《99%隐形》。我是罗曼·马尔斯。芭芭拉·维瑟第一次见到它时才9岁。当时她正参加学校去阿姆斯特丹市中心市立博物馆的实地考察。我猜那是1975年左右。可以说那是该博物馆的全盛时期。他们确实处于现代和当代艺术的最前沿。市立博物馆的建筑旨在给人留下深刻印象。有一条巨大的楼梯通向光亮处，某种程度上，有点像圣经里的场景，一条楼梯，
not to heaven, but almost to heaven to the whole of honors. The Hall of Honors displayed some of the museum's finest paintings, but one in particular dominated the room. The tour guide led Barbara in her class over. And this painting, it struck me like lightning and not in a positive way. Which he saw was a massive canvas, nearly 18 feet wide and 8 feet tall on the left side a small strip of blue on the right a Small strip of yellow But the rest of the surface was painted entirely red this majestic fire truck red and
不是通往天堂，但几乎通往荣誉殿堂。荣誉殿堂展示了博物馆一些最精美的画作，但其中一幅画尤其占据了整个房间。导游带着芭芭拉和她的同学们走了过去。而这幅画，它像闪电一样击中了我，而且不是以一种积极的方式。她看到的是一幅巨大的画布，宽近18英尺，高8英尺，左侧有一小条蓝色，右侧有一小条黄色，但表面的其余部分完全涂成了红色，这种雄伟的消防车红，而且
It kind of annoyed me. I It's really I I didn't know what to look at, where to stare, what to do with it. And the only thing that the guide shared with us was the title. And the title is a question. Who's afraid of red, yellow and blue? And I got very angry. I ran out of the museum. I sat on the steps and was determined not to go in again. The full title of the painting Barbara saw that day is Who's Afraid of Red Yellow and Blue 3
这让我有点恼火。我真的不知道该看哪里，该盯着哪里，该拿它怎么办。导游与我们分享的唯一信息就是标题。标题是一个问题。谁害怕红、黄、蓝？我非常生气。我跑出了博物馆。我坐在台阶上，下定决心再也不进去了。芭芭拉那天看到的画的全名是《谁害怕红、黄、蓝 3》，
by the American post-war artist, Barnett Newman. Producer John Feseo brings us this tale from the galleries of Amsterdam. Usually, you walk in a museum, you see a painting, you think about it for a moment, maybe feel something, and walk away. Not this one. This was a painting that would produce such strong reactions in people that they did more than just think about it.
由美国战后艺术家巴尼特·纽曼创作。制片人约翰·费塞奥为我们带来了这个来自阿姆斯特丹画廊的故事。通常，你走进博物馆，看到一幅画，你会思考片刻，也许会有所感触，然后走开。但这幅画不同。这是一幅会在人们心中产生如此强烈反应的画，以至于他们不仅仅是思考它。
In the end, Barbara got off easy. She only struggled with the painting her entire life and made a feature-length documentary about it. It's called The End of Fear and Inspire This Story. And this story is about a reaction the painting received that was so intense, so violent. It set off a chain of events that shook the art world to its core. It wasn't easy art, to say the least.
最后，芭芭拉还算轻松。她只是终其一生都在与这幅画作斗争，并为此制作了一部专题纪录片。它叫《恐惧的终结与启发这个故事》。而这个故事是关于这幅画所引发的反应，它是如此强烈，如此暴力。它引发了一连串事件，震撼了整个艺术界。至少可以说，这不是容易理解的艺术。
But first, why this painting? The problem of the subject became very clear to me as the crucial thing in painting. Barnett Newman was a late bloomer. A substitute art teacher turned, art critic turned artist. He didn't have his first solo show until he was almost 45. He was this portly Jewish guy with a big friendly mustache who wore a lot of bow ties and went by the nickname Barney. And he quickly became the de facto spokesman for a new art movement called Abstract Expressionism. A painter is a kind of choreographer of space and creates kind of a dance of elements of forms.
但首先，为什么是这幅画？主题的问题变得非常清晰，成为绘画中的关键。巴尼特·纽曼是大器晚成的人。他曾是代课美术老师，后来成为艺术评论家，最后成为艺术家。直到快45岁时，他才举办了第一次个展。他是一个身材魁梧的犹太人，留着浓密友好的胡子，经常打领结，绰号叫巴尼。他很快成为了一个名为“抽象表现主义”的新艺术运动的实际代言人。画家是一种空间的编舞者，创造了一种元素和形式的舞蹈。
Abstract Expressionism came out of New York after World War II. The movement produced painters like Jackson Pollock, Mark Rothko, and Helen Frankenthaller. Artists known for big canvases full of wild colors, shapes, and splashes of paint. Like many abstract expressionists, artists, Newman struggled with what to paint in the aftermath of the war. After all, what could you paint after the Holocaust? After Hiroshima? What are we going to paint?
抽象表现主义出现在二战后的纽约。这场运动涌现了像杰克逊·波洛克、马克·罗斯科和海伦·弗兰肯瑟勒这样的画家。艺术家们以充满狂野色彩、形状和油漆泼溅的大型画布而闻名。像许多抽象表现主义艺术家一样，纽曼在战后也在思考该画什么。毕竟，大屠杀之后你能画什么？广岛之后呢？我们要画什么？
For Newman, answering this question required ignoring all of art history and starting from scratch, he began making large paintings, big, even by abstract expressionist standards, often filling the entire wall of a gallery. These paintings were physically big, and they felt even bigger. They featured very few colors, usually one solid hue, broken up by a few vertical stripes. But whatever you do, don't call them stripes. I did not decide to say to myself, I'm going to paint stripes.
对纽曼来说，回答这个问题需要忽略所有的艺术史，从零开始。他开始创作大型画作，即使以抽象表现主义的标准来看也很大，通常填满画廊的整面墙。这些画在物理上很大，而且感觉更大。它们使用的颜色很少，通常是一种纯色，被几条垂直的条纹打破。但无论你做什么，都不要称它们为条纹。我并没有决定对自己说，我要画条纹。
Newman preferred to call them zips. I feel that my zip does not divide my painting. I feel it does the exact opposite. It unites the thing. It creates a totality. In 1967, Newman finished what would prove to be one of his largest paintings, who's afraid of red, yellow, and blue. Three.
纽曼更喜欢称它们为“拉链”（zips）。我觉得我的“拉链”并没有分割我的画。我觉得它恰恰相反。它统一了事物。它创造了一个整体。1967年，纽曼完成了他最大的一幅画作，即《谁害怕红、黄、蓝 3》。
It was the third in a series. The title was a reference to who's afraid of Virginia Woolf. A landmark play, later a movie, starring Elizabeth Taylor and Richard Burton, about a relationship full of miscommunication. Be careful, Martha. I'll rip you to pieces. Accusal. You are not enough.
这是该系列的第三幅。标题参考了《谁害怕弗吉尼亚·伍尔夫》。这是一部具有里程碑意义的戏剧，后来被改编成电影，由伊丽莎白·泰勒和理查德·伯顿主演，讲述了一段充满误解的关系。小心，玛莎。我会把你撕成碎片。指责。你还不够。
You happen to guts and vitriol. Total total. In a sense, this big red painting with a slender zip of blue on the left and a slender zip of blue on the left and a slender zip of yellow on the right was Newman's way of saying, this is what a painting can do. But what was the painting doing exactly? Barbara Visser says that when the state-elect museum acquired who's afraid of Fred Yellow and Blue 3 in 1969, a lot of people did not like it.
你碰巧有胆量和尖刻。完全，完全。从某种意义上说，这幅巨大的红色画作，左侧有一条细细的蓝色“拉链”，右侧有一条细细的黄色“拉链”，是纽曼表达“这就是绘画能做到的”方式。但这幅画到底在做什么？芭芭拉·维瑟说，当市立博物馆在1969年购入《谁害怕红、黄、蓝 3》时，很多人并不喜欢它。
Actually, let's go with despise. People despised it. At the time, people would write really long and elaborate letters to say how much they hated this painting. The painting evoked a common complaint about abstract art, which is to throw your hands up and say, why is this art? I paid to see art, damn it, not red paint on a canvas. Anybody can do that. There was one woman who expressed that it really nauseated her and it really, literally made her sick. She felt it would better be hung out of sight,
实际上，我们用“鄙视”这个词。人们鄙视它。当时，人们会写非常长且详尽的信，表达他们有多讨厌这幅画。这幅画引发了对抽象艺术的一个常见抱怨，那就是双手一摊说：“这为什么是艺术？该死，我付钱是为了看艺术，而不是画布上的红漆。任何人都能做到。”有一位女士表示，这让她感到恶心，甚至真的让她生病了。她觉得最好把它挂在看不见的地方，
somewhere in the coach's... the coach check. In 1986, the painting was the centerpiece of an exhibit called The Grand Parade. La grande parade is precisely what they said to be. The purpose of which was to raise exactly this question of what a painting is or isn't. But a feisty update from the high points. is exactly this question of what a painting is or isn't. And that's when the negative opinions of who's afraid of red, yellow, and blue three were taken to a whole new level. At the time, Barbara was in art school. Somehow in the corridors of the school, people whispered,
比如在衣帽间。1986年，这幅画是一个名为《大游行》展览的核心展品。《大游行》正是他们所说的。其目的是提出关于“什么是绘画，什么不是”的问题。而这正是关于“什么是绘画，什么不是”的问题。就在那时，对《谁害怕红、黄、蓝 3》的负面评价达到了一个全新的高度。当时，芭芭拉正在读艺术学校。不知何故，在学校的走廊里，人们窃窃私语，
how did you hear it? Something happened at the Stadley Museum. You couldn't really verify it. I was on my way to the Stadley Museum for a meeting. Petra Tinkata, an artist and educator, walked into the Stadley Lake that afternoon. Once there, she headed to the gallery where who's afraid of red-yellow three was hanging. And then I came upon that room and there I saw this painting of just a start.
你是怎么听说的？市立博物馆发生了一些事。你无法真正核实。我当时正要去市立博物馆开会。佩特拉·廷卡塔，一位艺术家和教育家，那天下午走进了市立博物馆。到达后，她前往悬挂《谁害怕红、黄、蓝 3》的画廊。然后我走进了那个房间，在那里我看到了这幅画，简直惊呆了。
An attendant stood in the corner to petrified to move. The painting had just been attacked. And the man who did sitting quietly on the bench had stabbed the painting with a box cutter, tracing a series of long slashes through the very center of the canvas. The canvas had lost its tension and sagged, turning the cuts in the lopsided smiles and exposing the white wall behind. Petra took it all in. And I saw it in a blink and then I ran away. She went to find the museum's curator.
一名服务员站在角落里，吓得动弹不得。这幅画刚刚遭到袭击。那个坐在长椅上安静地做这件事的男人用美工刀刺伤了这幅画，在画布的正中央划出了一系列长长的裂口。画布失去了张力，下垂了，使切口变成了歪斜的笑脸，露出了后面的白墙。佩特拉目睹了一切。我一眼就看到了，然后跑开了。她去找博物馆的馆长。
And I screamed, the painting is destroyed. It's murder. I screamed, the painting is destroyed. It's murder. I remember I got a call and I think it was in a weekend. And I was at home. Icebrown, Humelin is an art conservation expert in the Netherlands. And even though he didn't work at the Stadelic, he was called in that day, along with the police.
我尖叫道：“画被毁了。这是谋杀。”我尖叫道：“画被毁了。这是谋杀。”我记得我接到一个电话，我想是在周末。我当时在家。伊斯布兰德·胡梅林是荷兰的艺术修复专家。尽管他不在市立博物馆工作，但他那天和警察一起被叫去了。
The director was there and a lot of people were around at least 20 people were around and there was a lot of tension. The painting was laid out in the middle of the gallery. They had it on the ground already, face down. Could you see the slashes? Yes, from the backside, of course. The slashes, when added up together, measured nearly 50 feet long. Petra and Isbrand couldn't quite believe it. That's all I remember of the day.
馆长在那里，周围至少有20个人，气氛非常紧张。这幅画被平放在画廊中央。他们已经把它放在地上了，正面朝下。你能看到裂口吗？是的，当然是从背面。这些裂口加起来总长近50英尺。佩特拉和伊斯布兰德简直不敢相信。这就是我那天记得的一切。
They're so awful. The attacker's name was Herard Jan Van Bladren. ["Why did he do it?" I didn't ask him. ["He was 31, unemployed, living with his parents, Why did he do it? I did ask him. He was 31, unemployed, living with his parents, and he was a painter himself, although not very successful. Barbara looked into his past.
它们太可怕了。袭击者的名字是赫拉德·扬·范·布拉德伦。“他为什么要这么做？”我没问他。“他31岁，失业，和父母住在一起，他为什么要这么做？我确实问过他。他31岁，失业，和父母住在一起，他自己也是个画家，尽管不太成功。”芭芭拉调查了他的过去。
I haven't seen his, his, his, his early work before he attacked the painting, but I know that his action was regarded by him as an artistic gesture. Von Bladerin came from a school of thought that valued things like landscapes and figures. He hated abstract art and saw the painting as a kind of cultural provocation. And one of the main arguments that his lawyer made in his defence was that the provocation that the work inevitably is called for an action and got one.
我没见过他在袭击这幅画之前的早期作品，但我知道他的行为被他视为一种艺术姿态。范·布拉德伦来自一个重视风景画和人物画的思想流派。他讨厌抽象艺术，并将这幅画视为一种文化挑衅。他的律师在辩护中提出的主要论点之一是，作品不可避免地引发了挑衅，从而导致了行动。
Even as one Bladrin was being sentenced to five months in prison, he stood by his actions as a defense of artistic values, and many people in the Netherlands agreed. They sent letters to the state-elic. This so-called vandal should be made the director of modern museums, Red One. He did what hundreds of thousands of us would have liked to do, red another. Do you think that this painting was designed to upset people? That's an interesting question. I think the provocation was not the first intention of the work, but I do think that a title
即使在范·布拉德伦被判处五个月监禁时，他仍坚持自己的行为是对艺术价值的捍卫，荷兰的许多人也表示赞同。他们给市立博物馆写信。“这个所谓的破坏者应该被任命为现代博物馆的馆长，”有人写道。另一个人写道：“他做了我们成千上万人都想做的事。”你认为这幅画是为了让人们心烦意乱而设计的吗？这是一个有趣的问题。我认为挑衅并不是作品的首要意图，但我确实认为像那样的标题，
like that, because it's a question, demands an answer. The painting was meant to challenge you, although by all accounts, Newman who died in 1970 would have been horrified by what happened. While Van Blader and Satin prison, the canvas of whose afraid of red yellow and blue three remained in tatters. Icebron and other experts wondered if it could be restored. Their initial prognosis was grim. All paintings, damage paintings can be tweaked. But you don't know what the result will be.
因为它是一个问题，所以需要一个答案。这幅画旨在挑战你，尽管据各方说法，1970年去世的纽曼会对发生的事情感到震惊。当范·布拉德伦在监狱里时，《谁害怕红、黄、蓝 3》的画布仍然破烂不堪。伊斯布兰德和其他专家想知道它是否可以修复。他们最初的预测很严峻。旧画、受损的画可以进行微调。但你不知道结果会怎样。
And in this case, of course, I realized that this would be an enormous job, or maybe an impossible job. These things look like anybody could do it. That's not the case. It's not. Carol Mankusi-Ungaro from the Whitney Museum is one of the leading experts in the field of art conservation. The terminology in America is conservation, not restoration. Okay, good to know.
在这种情况下，我当然意识到这将是一项艰巨的工作，或者可能是一项不可能完成的工作。这些东西看起来好像谁都能做。事实并非如此。不是的。来自惠特尼博物馆的卡罗尔·曼库西-翁加罗是艺术修复领域的主要专家之一。在美国，术语是“保护”（conservation），而不是“修复”（restoration）。好的，知道了。
Carol has pioneered techniques for restoring work by modern and contemporary artists. She's worked on several paintings by Barnett Newman. I've been in this business for a long time, 40 years, golly. She says that there are set rules that conservators must follow when repairing a painting. And reversibility is a carnal rule of conservation. We make every effort to not use any material that cannot be removed or reversed in the future. For example, if conservators add paint to a canvas, they want to make sure that paint can be dissolved and removed later. They do this in case the artwork needs to be retouched again in the future.
卡罗尔开创了修复现代和当代艺术家作品的技术。她曾修复过巴尼特·纽曼的几幅画作。“我从事这一行已经很长时间了，40年了，天哪。”她说，修复者在修复画作时必须遵循既定的规则。可逆性是保护工作的核心规则。“我们尽一切努力不使用任何将来无法移除或逆转的材料。”例如，如果修复者在画布上添加颜料，他们要确保这些颜料以后可以溶解并移除。他们这样做是为了以防艺术品将来需要再次修补。
Conservators also try to preserve as much of the original material as possible, touching only the areas that need treatment. And they really study the artists and look at their past work. In order to get a sense of what the artist was trying to achieve. With these rules in mind, the Stadelic phoned up practically every conservator in Europe as they tried to figure out how to repair who's afraid of Red Yellow and Blue 3
修复者还试图尽可能多地保留原始材料，只触及需要处理的区域。他们确实研究艺术家并查看他们过去的作品，以便了解艺术家试图实现的目标。带着这些规则，市立博物馆给欧洲几乎所有的修复者打了电话，试图找出如何修复《谁害怕红、黄、蓝 3》
and its 50 feet worth of slashes. They held conferences with the best people in the business and they couldn't really agree on what was the best way to do it. The biggest challenge, perhaps counterintuitively, was the very simplicity of the painting. The busy texture and detail of a Picasso or Rembrandt often helps mask the repair work. But Newman's canvas was mostly just one big swath of uniform color. Any sign of repair, however minor, would be sure to stand out. So most conservators were too scared to try.
以及它那50英尺长的裂口。他们与业内最优秀的人士举行了会议，但他们无法就最佳方案达成一致。最大的挑战，也许出乎意料的是，正是这幅画的极简主义。毕加索或伦勃朗作品中繁忙的纹理和细节通常有助于掩盖修复痕迹。但纽曼的画布大部分只是一大片均匀的颜色。任何修复的迹象，无论多么微小，都肯定会引人注目。所以大多数修复者都太害怕而不敢尝试。
Nobody wanted to burn their hands on it, as we say. But someone finally came to the rescue. Daniel Goldvier was a conservator based in New York who had worked with Newman while he was still alive. They approached him, Daniel Goldreyer, and asked whether he was fit to do it. He was very optimistic. He said he could mend it with 98% success.
正如我们所说，没人想烧到自己的手。但最终有人来救场了。丹尼尔·戈德雷尔是一位常驻纽约的修复者，曾在纽曼在世时与他合作过。他们联系了他，丹尼尔·戈德雷尔，询问他是否胜任。他非常乐观。他说他能以98%的成功率修复它。
This is 98% restorable. I'm Daniel Goldryer. Goldryer promised that when he was done, the slashes would be virtually invisible. The officials at the Stadalic breathed a sigh of relief, and in 1987, who's afraid of Red Yellow and Blue 3 was rolled up, put in a narrow coffin-like box, and carried solemnly down the steps of the museum.
这是98%可修复的。我是丹尼尔·戈德雷尔。戈德雷尔承诺，当他完成时，裂口将几乎不可见。市立博物馆的官员们松了一口气，1987年，《谁害怕红、黄、蓝 3》被卷起来，放进一个狭窄的棺材状盒子里，庄严地抬下了博物馆的台阶。
Then it was shipped off to Goldriar Studio in New York. From that time on, the state like didn't hear much about it. Goldriar said, this is not a small job, so please leave me to do the job. A year past, then two, then three. Eventually the museum is like, oh, what's up with our painting? He said, we're doing fine, we're doing fine. We'll keep you posted. Another year passed, they asked again.
然后它被运往纽约的戈德雷尔工作室。从那时起，市立博物馆就没怎么听到关于它的消息了。戈德雷尔说：“这不是一个小工程，所以请让我来做这项工作。”一年过去了，两年，三年。最终博物馆问：“哦，我们的画怎么样了？”他说：“我们做得很好，我们做得很好。我们会随时通知你们。”又过了一年，他们再次询问。
Finally, four and a half years later, Goldroyer unveiled the painting. And when the museum director, a guy named Vim Beeren, came to inspect his work, there was no sign of the slashes. The damage had been erased. Who's afraid of red, yellow and blue, three was headed back to Amsterdam. Shortly after, it exhibited again, the press is invited. The bire speaks of the return of the lost son. They try to make it a very festive moment.
最终，四年半后，戈德雷尔揭开了这幅画的面纱。当博物馆馆长，一个叫维姆·比伦的人，来检查他的工作时，没有裂口的迹象。损坏已经被抹去了。《谁害怕红、黄、蓝 3》被送回了阿姆斯特丹。不久之后，它再次展出，媒体受邀参加。比伦谈到了“浪子回头”。他们试图让它成为一个非常喜庆的时刻。
But on that first day back, visitors to the museum began to notice something. To keep people from getting too close to the painting, the museum had installed a low fence. One guy there, a conservator who didn't work for the museum, decided to hop it. He really wanted to smell the work, you know, not just look at it from a distance. And he looked at it and he said,
但在回来的第一天，博物馆的参观者开始注意到一些事情。为了防止人们离画太近，博物馆安装了一个低矮的围栏。那里有一个人，一个不在博物馆工作的修复者，决定跳过去。他真的很想闻闻这件作品，你知道，不仅仅是从远处看。他看了看，然后说，
I'm not seeing what I saw before. This is something else. Icebrand was there that day too. I immediately recognized it also. It was like a wall, a lot of paint wall, you know, dull, no tension. Yes, the slushes had been repaired and yes, the surface was still red, but before there had been depth to the red, a shimmering quality. That was all gone. How did you feel? Incredible, disappointed, and, uh, well, set.
“我没看到我以前看到的东西。这是别的东西。”伊斯布兰德那天也在场。“我也立刻认出来了。它就像一堵墙，很多油漆墙，你知道，沉闷，没有张力。”是的，裂口已经修复了，是的，表面仍然是红色的，但在那之前，红色是有深度的，有一种闪烁的质感。那一切都消失了。你感觉如何？难以置信，失望，而且，呃，很难过。
Very set. Very set. Yeah. Did you feel like the painting had been ruined? Yes. Yeah sad. Very sad. Yeah. Did you feel like the painting had been ruined? Yes. Yeah, a ruling kiss. At first, the museum tried to deny it. The director was like, what are you talking about? It looks good as new. But everybody else was like, dude, come on.
非常难过。非常难过。是的。你觉得这幅画被毁了吗？是的。是的，悲伤。非常悲伤。是的。你觉得这幅画被毁了吗？是的。是的，一个毁灭性的吻。起初，博物馆试图否认。馆长说：“你在说什么？它看起来和新的一样。”但其他人都说：“伙计，拜托。”
The City Council of Amsterdam, which owned the museum and technically owned the painting, sent it to a forensic lab to figure out what gold-riar had done. Now, in the lab, they made cross-sections of the layers of paint, because usually a painting, especially in oil painting, it's not one layer, it's many different layers. Like the layers in the ground, you know? like archaeologists use these layers in the ground. You see all the paint layers under the microscope. They took these tiny samples from the red part of the painting and compared them to earlier samples that ice brand and the others had pulled off the gallery floor.
阿姆斯特丹市议会拥有该博物馆，从技术上讲也拥有这幅画，他们将其送到法医实验室，以查明戈德雷尔做了什么。现在，在实验室里，他们制作了油漆层的横截面，因为通常一幅画，尤其是油画，不是一层，而是许多不同的层。就像地下的层一样，你知道吗？就像考古学家使用地下的这些层一样。你在显微镜下看到了所有的油漆层。他们从画的红色部分取了这些微小的样本，并将它们与伊斯布兰德和其他人从画廊地板上取下的早期样本进行了比较。
The day the painting was slashed. And then it was very, very, very clear that there were four layers of paint on top of the original ones. And the four layers of new flat dull paint didn't just cover the areas that had been slashed. Gold-Ryre had painted over the entire red part of the canvas. So basically the whole painting. And Gold-Ryre hadn't used oil paint, which is what Newman had used. He'd used a type of acrylic paint known as Al-Qaeda. What you use for house paint? House paint.
画被划破的那天。然后非常非常清楚地表明，原始油漆层上面有四层油漆。而且这四层新的平坦、沉闷的油漆不仅覆盖了被划破的区域。戈德雷尔把画布的整个红色部分都涂了一遍。基本上是整幅画。而且戈德雷尔没有使用纽曼使用的油漆，即油画颜料。他使用了一种被称为“醇酸树脂”的丙烯酸涂料。你用来刷房子的那种油漆？房屋涂料。
This dries this house paint very hard in 10 years. It becomes very hard and very impossible actually to take off. And that's not all. There were also splatters of red paints on the blue and yellow zips at either side of the canvas, which indicated that gold-ryer had used a paint roller. Gold-ryer had rolled over the entire canvas of a 20th century masterpiece with house paint. Who's afraid of red, yellow, and blue-three have been murdered? Again.
这种房屋涂料在10年内会干得非常硬。它变得非常坚硬，实际上根本无法去除。而且还不止于此。画布两侧的蓝色和黄色“拉链”上也有红漆溅出，这表明戈德雷尔使用了油漆滚筒。戈德雷尔用房屋涂料滚过了20世纪杰作的整个画布。《谁害怕红、黄、蓝 3》被谋杀了。再次。
Theories abound as to what went wrong in that Long Island studio. Maybe Gold-Ryre bluffed his way into the job, realized it was a nearly impossible task and panicked. Not everyone felt he'd ruined the painting. Burnett Newman's widow, for instance, thought he did a good job, although she hadn't seen it in good lighting. Publicly, Goldriar insisted he hadn't painted over the canvas.
关于那个长岛工作室出了什么问题，理论层出不穷。也许戈德雷尔虚张声势地接下了这份工作，意识到这是一项几乎不可能完成的任务，然后惊慌失措。并不是每个人都觉得他毁了这幅画。例如，巴尼特·纽曼的遗孀认为他做得很好，尽管她没有在良好的光线下看过它。公开场合，戈德雷尔坚称他没有覆盖画布。
He said he had pinpointed the damaged area with two million tiny dots. He said I did not overpaint this painting. Yeah, that was really a lie because we could prove it. Even though they'd just proven all this, the statelic was in a bind. Because the museum's director had signed off on the restoration, gold-riar suit for defamation, and the museum settled. The whole affair cost over a million bucks, and to this day, they're stuck with a damaged painting. And they can't really talk about that damage. That was part of the settlement. But fortunately for us, Carol Mungusi-Tungaro from the Whitney can talk about it.
他说他用两百万个微小的点精准定位了受损区域。他说：“我没有重绘这幅画。”是的，那真的是个谎言，因为我们可以证明。尽管他们刚刚证明了这一切，但市立博物馆陷入了困境。因为博物馆馆长签署了修复协议，戈德雷尔起诉诽谤，博物馆达成了和解。整个事件花费了超过一百万美元，直到今天，他们还被困在一幅受损的画作中。而且他们不能真正谈论那种损坏。那是和解协议的一部分。但幸运的是，惠特尼博物馆的卡罗尔·曼库西-翁加罗可以谈论它。
When you look at a work of art, it's primarily a flat color. When you look at that work of art cold, you kind of say, well, what are you talking about? It's just one flat color. You know, anybody can do that. Just repaint it. You know, what's the big deal? That might have been what Goldriar was thinking.
当你看着一件艺术品时，它主要是一种平坦的颜色。当你冷眼看那件艺术品时，你会说：“好吧，你在说什么？它只是一种平坦的颜色。你知道，任何人都能做到。重绘它就行了。你知道，这有什么大不了的？”这可能就是戈德雷尔当时的想法。
The fact is, Barnett Newman did sometimes use paint rollers in his work. But he didn't use a roller for this painting. Again, these things might look like anybody can make them, but Newman's process was complex. He worked his surfaces so well that you're never aware of a brushstroke. You're never aware of a roller pattern. He worked those surfaces so the only thing that you saw and the only thing you
事实是，巴尼特·纽曼有时确实在他的作品中使用油漆滚筒。但他并没有在这幅画中使用滚筒。同样，这些东西看起来好像任何人都能制作，但纽曼的过程很复杂。他处理表面的方式非常精妙，以至于你永远不会意识到笔触。你永远不会意识到滚筒的图案。他处理那些表面，所以你看到的唯一东西和你
remember is the color. In a way, Goldriar's restoration of the painting, this second murder, was even worse than what the slasher had done. Because he didn't even acknowledge the painting. If the forensic analysis is correct, then he just rolled over it, like it was the side of a tool shed, and then lied. The slasher was at least responding to the painting. There was some honesty there. Which makes what happened next so ironic and maybe inevitable. In 1997, 11 years after the slashing, Van Bladeren, the slasher, found out about the botched restoration of who's afraid of Red Yellow and Blue 3.
记住的唯一东西就是颜色。在某种程度上，戈德雷尔对这幅画的修复，这第二次谋杀，甚至比袭击者所做的还要糟糕。因为他甚至没有承认这幅画。如果法医分析是正确的，那么他只是滚过了它，就像它是工具棚的侧面一样，然后撒了谎。袭击者至少是在回应这幅画。那里有一些诚实。这使得接下来发生的事情如此讽刺，也许是不可避免的。1997年，在划破事件发生11年后，袭击者范·布拉德伦发现了《谁害怕红、黄、蓝 3》修复失败的事。
Apparently, he too believed that the painting had been robbed of its original power, even if he had hated it, So he called the museum. He was put through to the new director, a man named Rudy Fuchs. Fuchs recorded the call. The attacker tells Fuchs that what he did in 1986, he would do that again to the restored painting. Should I cut it up again? The slasher asks.
显然，他也认为这幅画被剥夺了原始的力量，即使他曾经讨厌它。所以他给博物馆打了电话。他被转接给了新馆长，一个叫鲁迪·福克斯的人。福克斯录下了通话。袭击者告诉福克斯，他在1986年所做的事，他会再次对修复后的画作做一遍。“我应该再把它切开吗？”袭击者问。
Obviously not, Fuchs replants. But it's been totally fucked up, the slasher says. That's your opinion, says Fuchs. For a moment it's quiet and he's apparently thinking about that, then he says, okay, okay, I know now what to do. And really, Fuchs answers, well, I wouldn't do what you think you have to do. And then the conversation ends. After this phone call, Van Bladerin returns to the museum. He enters unrecognized.
“显然不行，”福克斯回答。“但它已经被彻底搞砸了，”袭击者说。“那是你的观点，”福克斯说。片刻安静，他显然在思考这个问题，然后他说：“好吧，好吧，我现在知道该怎么做了。”福克斯回答：“好吧，我不会做你认为你必须做的事。”然后谈话结束了。这次通话后，范·布拉德伦回到了博物馆。他未被认出就进去了。
And he looks around for who's afraid of red, yellow and blue three. But the painting is not on display at that moment. He came to the museum with very clear intentions, and it must be hard for him not to find that work. So instead, he goes and finds another painting by Barnett Newman, a large blue painting with a white zip down the middle called Cathedral. That's another moment in my life I will never forget.
他四处寻找《谁害怕红、黄、蓝 3》。但那幅画当时没有展出。他带着非常明确的意图来到博物馆，找不到那件作品对他来说一定很难。所以他转而寻找巴尼特·纽曼的另一幅画，一幅中间有一条白色“拉链”的蓝色大画，名叫《大教堂》。那是我生命中永远不会忘记的另一个时刻。
Rudy Fuchs, the museum's director, called Carol Mankousi-Ungaro right after it happened. You know, it was a phone call from Rudy Fuchs, director of Schedler. Look, that was a big deal. So I immediately went to my office to take the phone call. And he told me that Cathedral had been slashed and I swear the hair on my arms just stood up. I could not believe that it had happened and it was the same person. For the second time, Hierard Jan Van Bladerin had attacked a Barnett Newman painting with a knife. When he was done, he threw a packet of pamphlets on the floor that contained rambling, incoherent writing.
博物馆馆长鲁迪·福克斯在事情发生后立即给卡罗尔·曼库西-翁加罗打了电话。“你知道，那是来自市立博物馆馆长鲁迪·福克斯的电话。看，那是一件大事。所以我立刻回到办公室接听电话。”他告诉我《大教堂》被划破了，我发誓我手臂上的汗毛都竖起来了。我无法相信它发生了，而且是同一个人。赫拉德·扬·范·布拉德伦第二次用刀袭击了巴尼特·纽曼的画作。当他完成后，他在地板上扔了一包传单，里面包含着杂乱无章、语无伦次的文字。
The other sad aspect of it was the slash marks were exactly the same. They were so similar to the earlier attack that it became known as the artist's signature, the Flasher's signature. At his second trial, Von Blatteren was declared mentally unfit and sent to a psychiatric institution. Von Blatteren's attacks may have been motivated by mental illness, but in the era of public art, they're part of a long, sad history of vandalism. Picasso's Guernica was spray painted in the 70s. Acid has been thrown at Rembrandt's. Two Michelangelo sculptures have been attacked with hammers.
另一个悲伤的方面是划痕完全一样。它们与之前的袭击非常相似，以至于它被称为“艺术家的签名”，即“划破者的签名”。在第二次审判中，范·布拉德伦被宣布精神不健全，并被送往精神病院。范·布拉德伦的袭击可能是由精神疾病引起的，但在公共艺术时代，它们是漫长而悲伤的破坏历史的一部分。毕加索的《格尔尼卡》在70年代被喷漆。伦勃朗的画作被泼过酸。两座米开朗基罗的雕塑被锤子袭击过。
Numan's work in particular has been vandalized multiple times, and these weren't artistic gestures. Remember, Numan's a Jewish artist. Who's afraid of Red Yellow and Blue 4, the sequel to Who's Afraid of Red Yellow and Blue 3, was struck and spat upon in Germany. Because the attacker said, it bore a mocking resemblance to the German flag. A Newman sculpture at a museum in Houston was spray painted with swastikas in 1979.
纽曼的作品尤其多次遭到破坏，这些都不是艺术姿态。记住，纽曼是一位犹太艺术家。《谁害怕红、黄、蓝 4》，即《谁害怕红、黄、蓝 3》的续作，在德国被击打和吐口水。因为袭击者说，它带有对德国国旗的嘲弄。1979年，休斯顿一家博物馆的一座纽曼雕塑被喷上了纳粹标志。
And just last year, someone poured white paint into the reflecting pool surrounding the same sculpture and left behind white supremacist leaflets. If you're keeping track, that's four Barnett Newman works to face a total of five times. Six, if you include Daniel Goldryer's botched restoration. And those are just the ones we know of. The Barnett Newman Foundation refused to speak to me for this story because they have a really legitimate fear of copycat vandalism. Sure. I think that's right.
就在去年，有人往环绕同一雕塑的倒影池里倒了白漆，并留下了白人至上主义的传单。如果你在记录，那是四件巴尼特·纽曼的作品总共被毁坏了五次。如果算上丹尼尔·戈德雷尔拙劣的修复，那就是六次。而这些只是我们知道的。巴尼特·纽曼基金会拒绝就这个故事接受我的采访，因为他们对模仿破坏行为有着非常合理的恐惧。当然。我想那是对的。
And, you know, maybe I shouldn't have agreed to talk to you for that reason. I'm concerned now. I hadn't thought about it myself. Carol almost made a break for it during our interview. I have to ask you a question. Yeah. How would you feel if after reading this, somebody went and slashed a painting? Oh.
而且，你知道，也许我不应该因为这个原因同意和你谈话。我现在很担心。我自己之前没想过。卡罗尔在我们的采访中差点逃跑。“我必须问你一个问题。”“是的。”“如果读了这些之后，有人去划破了一幅画，你会怎么想？”“哦。”
I would feel terrible. That would mean we failed. I know. Yeah. Because our paintings are so vulnerable. They're just out there in galleries. So I'm here at MoMA, the Museum of Modern Art in New York. It's a Friday night, it's really busy in here.
“我会感觉很糟糕。那意味着我们失败了。”“我知道。”“是的。因为我们的画作太脆弱了。它们只是挂在画廊里。”所以我现在在纽约现代艺术博物馆（MoMA）。这是一个周五晚上，这里非常繁忙。
When I was at MoMA recently, I saw this Barnett Newman painting titled, Veer Heroicist Supplements. The title of this painting translates to Man Heroic in Sublime. It was the size of a billboard. It looks a lot like who's afraid of Red, yellow, and blue, three. It's like red with a couple of streaks of like this purplish color and this orange color and this whitish color, but mostly red, mostly hugely red, like this one solid wall of red. The painting didn't provoke me, it didn't make me angry, like it did so many others.
最近我在MoMA时，看到了这幅巴尼特·纽曼的画，标题是《英雄崇高的人》。这幅画的标题翻译过来是“英雄崇高的人”。它有广告牌那么大。它看起来很像《谁害怕红、黄、蓝 3》。它就像红色，带有几条紫色的条纹，还有这种橙色和这种白色，但主要是红色，主要是巨大的红色，就像这一整面红色的墙。这幅画没有激怒我，它没有让我生气，不像对其他人那样。
And it didn't look simple either, like something you could just roll over with a paint roller. He was towering, impressive, dense. You just get up close to this thing, you really get lost in it. For a moment, I think I felt this feeling that I'd heard Icebrand talk about. Something that Newman tried to achieve in his work. Tested to do with the sublime. And the sublime experience is when you are alone in the deserts, in the night, and you see all this, you know, the enormous sky, and you feel very tiny.
它看起来也不简单，不像那种你可以用油漆滚筒滚过去的东西。它高耸、令人印象深刻、浓密。你靠近这东西，真的会迷失在其中。有一刻，我想我感受到了伊斯布兰德谈到的那种感觉。纽曼试图在他的作品中实现的东西。试图与崇高有关。而崇高的体验是当你独自在夜晚的沙漠中，你看到这一切，你知道，巨大的天空，你感到非常渺小。
You feel overwhelmed by it. This is a kind of feeling everybody knows, I think. It's just really overwhelming, to be honest. A painting is more than just a painting. It's more than the materials and the technique. It's the feeling it evokes in you, the viewer. And when you damage or destroy a piece of art, that's what you lose. That's the crime, that's the real crime. Diminishing the painting's power.
你感到被它淹没了。我认为这是一种每个人都知道的感觉。老实说，这真的很让人不知所措。一幅画不仅仅是一幅画。它不仅仅是材料和技术。它是它在你——观众心中唤起的感觉。当你损坏或摧毁一件艺术品时，你失去的就是那个。那是犯罪，那是真正的犯罪。削弱了画作的力量。
Yes. The experience of it. After Cathedral was attacked, both Icebrond and Carol advised on its restoration and the museum spared no expense. The canvas was stitched together with surgical sutures and orthodontic wire on a specially built table. Four painstaking years later, it was unveiled.
是的。它的体验。在《大教堂》遭到袭击后，伊斯布兰德和卡罗尔都对它的修复提供了建议，博物馆不惜一切代价。画布用手术缝合线和正畸钢丝在特制的桌子上缝合在一起。四年艰苦的工作后，它被揭幕了。
It's not perfect. If you know where to look and look closely, you can see the scars, but the impression survives. The painting can still take your breath away. Cathedral is currently on display at the Stadelic, but not who's afraid of red, yellow and blue three. It's a painting that is very close to everyone's heart at the museum and in Amsterdam.
它并不完美。如果你知道往哪里看并仔细观察，你可以看到伤疤，但印象留存了下来。这幅画仍然可以让你屏住呼吸。目前《大教堂》在市立博物馆展出，但《谁害怕红、黄、蓝 3》没有。这是一幅在博物馆和阿姆斯特丹每个人心中都非常亲近的画。
Yet we do all agree now that it's not what it used to be. The painting is sitting in a storage facility at the edge of town. It's too big to fit into the normal places that are reserved, so it stands by itself, kind of lonely against the wall. It waits there, hoping for a day when future conservators might be able to undo what was done to it. To remove the layers of paint and get to the original experience, the one the artist created, still sleeping underneath. John Feseel talks to me more about the coolest job in the world, after this. While he was working on this story, our reporter John Fassil really fell in love
然而我们现在都同意它已经不是原来的样子了。这幅画正放在城边的一个仓库里。它太大了，放不进预留的普通地方，所以它独自立着，靠在墙上，显得有点孤独。它在那里等待，希望有一天未来的修复者能够撤销对它所做的一切。去除那些油漆层，找回最初的体验，那个艺术家创造的、仍然沉睡在下面的体验。约翰·费塞奥将在之后与我谈论世界上最酷的工作。当他正在制作这个故事时，我们的记者约翰·费塞奥真的爱上了
with art conservation. There was a point in every conversation that I had with a conservator while working on this story where I'd be like, this is the coolest job. Like there is no better job than this. In fact, you can hear one of those moments in my interview with Icebrand. Yeah, I think you have maybe the best job in the world.
艺术保护。我在制作这个故事时与修复者进行的每一次谈话中，都有一个时刻我会说：“这是最酷的工作。”就像没有比这更好的工作了。事实上，你可以在我采访伊斯布兰德时听到其中一个时刻。“是的，我想你可能拥有世界上最好的工作。”
It sounds like a fantastic profession, I think. Daily, I enjoy it. Why do you like it so much? Why were you so enthralled? Well, conservators are sort of this hybrid of an artist, or they would probably say an artist's assistant, and one of those forensic scientists from CSI. So, first, you really have to think like an artist to try to preserve what, as Carol says,
“听起来是一份很棒的职业，我想。每天，我都乐在其中。”“你为什么这么喜欢它？你为什么如此着迷？”“嗯，修复者是艺术家——或者他们可能会说是艺术家的助手——和CSI那些法医科学家的一种混合体。所以，首先，你真的必须像艺术家一样思考，试图保护卡罗尔所说的，
the artist was trying to achieve with their work. And she actually spends a lot of her time interviewing living artists when she's restoring their work. She's built an archive of these interviews you can access online called the Artist Documentation Program. And they're just audio recordings of her interviewing artists about their process. But in addition to getting inside the mind of the artists, you also have to know chemistry and all this hard science stuff about the composition of materials that artists use. And there's some really far out technology
艺术家试图通过他们的作品实现的目标。事实上，她在修复在世艺术家的作品时，会花很多时间采访他们。她建立了一个你可以在线访问的这些采访档案，称为‘艺术家记录项目’。它们只是她采访艺术家关于他们过程的录音。但除了进入艺术家的内心世界，你还必须了解化学和所有关于艺术家使用的材料成分的硬科学知识。而且有一些非常前卫的技术
that they employ. And they're able to work miracles. And what kind of technology are we talking about? Let's start with imaging techniques, like photography. They have technology that allows them to see below the surface of the painting. Like the layers underneath the painting that Icebrown talked about in the story, infrared
他们使用。他们能够创造奇迹。你们在谈论什么样的技术？让我们从成像技术开始，比如摄影。他们拥有的技术使他们能够看到画作表面之下。就像伊斯布兰德在故事中谈到的画作下面的层，红外
reflectography, I'm not going to get too technical on you. They also bring paintings to hospitals to have them x-rayed. And that's not the only way this field overlaps with medicine actually, the conservators who stitched cathedra together in the Netherlands. They were actually trained at the hospital to do that. I talked to another conservator who had been a pre-med student before going into this field. So they're able to see below the surface of the painting using special types of photography and just plain old X-rays.
反射成像，我不会和你谈得太技术化。他们还把画作带到医院进行X光检查。事实上，这并不是这个领域与医学重叠的唯一方式，在荷兰缝合《大教堂》的修复者。他们实际上是在医院接受过培训才做到的。我采访了另一位修复者，他在进入这个领域之前曾是一名医学预科生。所以他们能够使用特殊类型的摄影和普通的X光看到画作表面之下。
They're also able to determine what elements are in the painting, like in the paint layers. So they have this thing, it sort of looks like a grocery store scanner, and they can scan all over the painting, and it'll identify the elements, like here's zinc, here's coalball. They can basically map the surface of the painting down to the atom in terms of the elements that are there. And they're also able to see, too to how the painting will fade over time. They have these tools that can measure and artwork sensitivity to light and project how it
他们还能够确定画作中有什么元素，比如在油漆层中。所以他们有这个东西，它看起来有点像杂货店的扫描仪，他们可以在画作上到处扫描，它会识别元素，比如这里有锌，这里有钴。他们基本上可以根据存在的元素将画作表面映射到原子层面。他们也能够看到，画作随着时间的推移会如何褪色。他们有这些工具可以测量艺术品对光的敏感度并预测它
will fade. So they can not only see under the surface of the painting and really inside the painting. They can also see into the future of that painting. Wow. Wow. Yeah. That's so cool. How do you use that information when you're trying to conserve a painting? So you can determine how much light it can be exposed to.
将如何褪色。所以他们不仅可以看到画作表面之下，还可以真正看到画作内部。他们还可以看到那幅画的未来。哇。哇。是的。太酷了。当你试图保护一幅画时，你如何使用这些信息？所以你可以确定它可以暴露在多少光线下。
Like, for instance, if you have a painting that is especially light-sensitive, you want to know not to place it like maybe in like the bright lights of a main hall or maybe design special lighting so that it doesn't fade the painting faster. Oh, so they're like trying to save a painting before it needs to be saved through these
比如，如果你有一幅特别对光敏感的画，你会想知道不要把它放在像主大厅明亮的灯光下，或者设计特殊的照明，这样它就不会更快地褪色。哦，所以他们就像试图在画作需要被拯救之前通过这些
steps of methods. Right, trying to save a painting before it needs to be saved. So in the case of this story, where gold-riar applied a bunch of this red paint in the effort to fix the painting, which a lot of people objected to, how would you go about removing paint from a painting without removing all the paint from a painting? If you really wanted to put it back to where it originally was. So very carefully. There's a couple different ways they remove stuff from the surface of artworks.
步骤方法来拯救它。是的，试图在画作需要被拯救之前拯救它。所以在那个故事中，戈德雷尔为了修复画作而涂了一堆红漆，很多人对此表示反对，你将如何从画作中去除油漆而不去除画作上的所有油漆？如果你真的想把它恢复到原来的样子。所以非常小心。他们有几种不同的方法可以从艺术品表面去除东西。
It's been added there that they don't want. Like they use emulsions and gels that dissolve material added to the surface of the artwork, but these are gels. They're like kind of viscous, you know, so it's not liquid, it doesn't run. And they're able to keep that really contained. They also use this stuff. I don't think it's been used a lot,
那是被添加在那里但他们不想要的。比如他们使用乳液和凝胶来溶解添加到艺术品表面的材料，但这些是凝胶。它们有点粘稠，你知道，所以它不是液体，它不会流淌。他们能够把那个控制得非常好。他们也使用这种东西。我不认为它被使用了很多，
but it's probably the coolest thing I've heard about while researching this story. They use atomic oxygen. What I'm about to say doesn't make sense, but it's literally oxygen from space. It's an elemental form of oxygen that does not exist in the earth's atmosphere. You only find it in low earth orbit.
但这可能是我在研究这个故事时听到的最酷的事情。他们使用原子氧。我接下来要说的话听起来可能不合逻辑，但它确实是来自太空的氧气。这是一种地球大气层中不存在的元素形式的氧气。你只能在近地轨道上找到它。
This technology is actually developed by NASA because atomic oxygen is like, they were studying corrosion on satellites in the International Space Station. And they basically either use like an airbrush and like have it very close to the painting or they put the piece of art in a vacuum chamber and pump in this stuff.
这项技术实际上是由美国国家航空航天局（NASA）开发的，因为原子氧……他们当时正在研究国际空间站上卫星的腐蚀问题。他们基本上要么使用喷枪，让它非常靠近画作，要么把艺术品放进真空室，然后注入这种物质。
It's really good for removing soot from fire damaged paintings. You can actually see some photos online of paintings they've restored that had been in fires, and it's pretty mind-blowing, actually. Like the before and after, it's like you have a picture of a blackened ruin painting, and on the other, you've got a completely restored work.
它非常适合清除火灾受损画作上的烟灰。你实际上可以在网上看到一些他们修复过的曾经历过火灾的画作的照片，这真的很令人震惊。比如修复前后的对比，一边是一幅被烧得漆黑的残破画作，另一边则是一件完全修复好的作品。
The atomic oxygen was always used to, most famously, to restore this painting by Andy Warhol called Bath tub, which is just a painting of a bathtub. And somebody at a party at the museum had kissed it, so there was a lipstick mark on it. They were able to remove it using atomic oxygen. And all these cases, conservatives had basically given up hope on those paintings.
原子氧最著名的用途是修复安迪·沃霍尔的一幅名为《浴缸》的画作，那只是一幅浴缸的画。博物馆里有人在聚会上亲吻了它，所以上面留下了一个唇印。他们能够使用原子氧将其去除。在所有这些案例中，文物保护人员基本上已经对这些画作不抱希望了。
They were like, these are never going to be restored. So with all this new technology, is it possible they could go back to really restore who's afraid of red, yellow, and blue. Number three, the way that you would really want it to be restored. Yeah, so the answer is maybe. Yeah, near the end of my reporting, I talked to a journalist in the Netherlands who had written a book on the state like his name was Yim Lemuré, he's a great resource. And a couple years ago, he was able to get the full results from the forensic lab analysis of who's afraid of Red Yelene Blue-3, the one that had determined that Goldriar had overpainted
他们当时觉得，这些画永远无法修复了。那么，有了所有这些新技术，他们是否有可能回去真正修复《谁害怕红、黄、蓝》第三号，以你真正希望的方式修复它呢？是的，答案也许是肯定的。在我的报道快结束时，我采访了荷兰的一位记者，他写过一本关于市立博物馆的书，他的名字叫伊姆·勒穆雷（Yim Lemuré），他是一个很好的信息来源。几年前，他设法获得了《谁害怕红、黄、蓝》第三号法医实验室分析的完整结果，正是那份分析确定了戈尔德里亚（Goldriar）进行了重绘。
it. So he was able to get the full thing released. And what the report showed, according to him, was that gold ryer had used several layers of varnish, which is like this clear kind of like a resin, that he used several layers of varnish before painting over the canvas. So theoretically, because he did that, the layers of paint above the varnish could be removed.
所以他设法让完整报告公之于众。据他所说，报告显示戈尔德里亚在画布上作画之前使用了几层清漆，这是一种透明的树脂。所以理论上，因为他那样做了，清漆上面的颜料层是可以被去除的。
Oh, what? So it is possible. Yeah, maybe not right now, but it is possible. I talked to Carol Mancusi-Yongaro from the Whitney about this, and she kind of agreed. I don't know. I don't know. I do know that I've seen my profession grow
哦，什么？所以这是可能的。是的，也许现在不行，但这是可能的。我与惠特尼博物馆的卡罗尔·曼库西-永加罗（Carol Mancusi-Yongaro）谈过这件事，她表示赞同。我不知道。我不知道。但我确实看到我的职业在成长，
and our ability to do things that one time we couldn't do. I believe that there may be procedures that we can do in the future that might be able to reverse this. So one day maybe, and I really hope the statelic is doing everything they can to see whether the painting can be restored because it'd be great to have it back. Absolutely. Well, cool. Thank you so much, Sean.
我们处理事情的能力在过去是无法实现的。我相信未来可能会有我们能做的程序，或许能够扭转这种局面。所以也许有一天，我真的希望市立博物馆正在尽其所能看看这幅画是否能被修复，因为如果能找回它就太好了。绝对是。好吧，太棒了。非常感谢你，肖恩。
Thank you. 99% Invisible was produced this week by John Fassil and edited by Joe Rosenberg. Mix and Tech Production by Sheree Fusef, Music by Sean Rial. Katie Mingle is our senior editor, Kurt Colstad is the digital director. The rest of the team includes senior editor, Gila Nehal, Avery Trouffleman, Emmett Fitzgerald,
谢谢。本周的《99%隐形》由约翰·法西尔（John Fassil）制作，乔·罗森伯格（Joe Rosenberg）编辑。混音和技术制作由谢丽·福塞夫（Sheree Fusef）负责，音乐由肖恩·里亚尔（Sean Rial）创作。凯蒂·明格尔（Katie Mingle）是我们的高级编辑，库尔特·科尔斯塔德（Kurt Colstad）是数字总监。团队的其他成员包括高级编辑吉拉·尼哈尔（Gila Nehal）、艾弗里·特鲁夫曼（Avery Trouffleman）、埃米特·菲茨杰拉德（Emmett Fitzgerald），
Taren Mazza, Vivian Lee, Sophia Klatsker, and me Roman Mars. Additional reporting for this story is from Boatah, Jelima Boatah is an audio producer in the Netherlands who also helped us on our series about the Belmer Mirror. So he's our man in Amsterdam. Thank you Boatah. Thanks also to Jim Lamaray, Hansen Hortageger,
塔伦·马扎（Taren Mazza）、薇薇安·李（Vivian Lee）、索菲亚·克拉茨克（Sophia Klatsker）以及我，罗曼·马斯（Roman Mars）。这个故事的额外报道来自博塔（Boatah），杰利马·博塔（Jelima Boatah）是荷兰的一位音频制作人，他也曾在我们关于贝尔默镜子的系列节目中帮助过我们。所以他是我们在阿姆斯特丹的人。谢谢你，博塔。也感谢吉姆·拉马雷（Jim Lamaray）、汉森·霍塔格（Hansen Hortageger），
John Wakefield, and Matt Scopeck. We are a project of 91.7KALW in San Francisco and produced on Radio Row in beautiful downtown Oakland, California. 99% invisible is a member of Radio Topia from PRX, a fiercely independent collective of the most innovative shows in all of podcasting. Find them all at radiotopia.fm. You can find the show in joint discussions about the show on Facebook. You can tweet at me at Roman Mars and the show at 99PI orc. We're on Instagram, Tumblr, and Reddit too. But if for some reason you're having a hard time picturing those Barnett Newman paintings,
约翰·韦克菲尔德（John Wakefield）和马特·斯科佩克（Matt Scopeck）。我们是旧金山91.7 KALW的一个项目，在加利福尼亚州美丽的奥克兰市中心广播街制作。99%隐形是PRX旗下RadioTopia的成员，这是一个由播客界最具创新性的节目组成的极其独立的集体。在radiotopia.fm上可以找到它们。你可以在Facebook上找到该节目并参与关于节目的讨论。你可以在Twitter上关注我@RomanMars，关注节目@99PIorg。我们也在Instagram、Tumblr和Reddit上。但如果由于某种原因你很难想象那些巴尼特·纽曼（Barnett Newman）的画作，
we got you covered at 99pi.org. video to be on. From PRX. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
我们在99pi.org上为你提供了帮助。视频即将推出。来自PRX。本集还没有评论。点击转录稿中的任何句子即可发表评论。